Let's look at the answer to our, when can we free the reservation stations quiz.
If the instruction cannot issue because there is no available reservation
station for it, that means that all of our reservation stations are busy.
With a processor that doesn't have a ROB,
we hold on to our reservation stations. From the time when we issue
the instruction until the time the instruction brought us a result. So issuing
of an instruction once the reservation stations are busy will have to wait for
the next instruction to broadcast the result. In contract,
in a ROB based processor with the same number of reservation stations,
we grab them at the same time, when we issue the instruction.
But, we free them as soon as we dispatch the instruction for
execution. So we free the reservation stations sooner, thus,
the next instruction might find the reservation station free over here.
Where over here it was still not available. So this situation is more likely
to happen when we do not have the ROB than when we do.